For this question, you're asked to find the element which occurs most often consecutively in a list
In this case, it's 5 because there are three 5s in a row,
and that's more than any of the other elements in row.
There are more 6s, but they're split. They're not in one consecutive list.
I'm going to talk about this as a sublist.
We're looking for the longest sublist of the same element repeated.
Now, in order to do that, we're going to have to keep track of some things.
We're going to have to keep track of our best element as we go.
We're going to have to keep track of how long the sublist containing the best element is.
As we go, we're going to have to keep increasing our count as we find another element
that's the same as the previous one.
For 6, we're going to have to keep track of the fact we're looking at 6
and the number of 6s that are occurring, so we can compare them with these two values here.
I'm going to introduce two more variables.
I'm going to introduce current and the current length.
To start off with, we haven't got any information, and we look at 7--
well, that's my current one, and there's one of them. Okay, I've got one 7.
That's definitely the best, because I haven't got anything else before, and there's one of them.
Now we move on from 7 and we get to 6. Well, there's one 6.
Move on again, and that's not better than we had before, so we're not going to replace best element with 6.
Now we come on to the second 6--oh, well, now we've got two 6s.
That's actually better than we had before.
I'm going to replace the 7 with a 6 and the length with 2.
We haven't got 6s anymore, so we're not going to increase the count for 6.
We're going to start a new count for 5.
We've got one 5, two 5s, three 5s, and now we're out of 5s.
Let's compare that with our best element from before.
It was 6 and there were only two of them, so 5 and 3 is better. There are more 5s.
Now we're not dealing with 5 anymore. We're dealing with 6 again.
There is one 6, two 6s.
Now, we compare the number of 6s with the number of 5s, and there aren't enough.
We're not going to replace the values there.
Then we come onto 7. There's one 7. Again, we're not going to replace the value.
Our procedure should return 5.
Now let's look at the code to do that.
We're going to define a procedure, longest_repetition, which has a list as its input.
Now, when we first start, we don't know what the best element is.
I'm going to set it none. It has length zero.
If it's an empty list, then there isn't a longest repetition, and the length would certainly be 0.
Our current--well, we don't have one either.
That's going to have length 0 as well.
What do we do? We looped through all the elements in the input list.
What are we going want to check?
Let's check to see if current is equal to the element or not.
If it's not equal to the element, then let's make it equal to the element,
and let's reset the current length to one, because we've now got an element ,
so it must occur at least once.
We don't know yet whether it'll occur more times, because we've only checked that first time
we've seen it in this sublist.
If current is equal to the element, then we're going to increase the length by 1,
because we've got a second one so our sublist is 1 longer than it was before.
In either case, we want to check whether the element we have is greater than the length
that we have stored as our best length of a sublist at the moment.
If it is better, then we're going to replace our best element with the current one,
and we're going to replace our length with the current length.
So when these for loops run through, all that there's left to do is return best_element.
That completes the code.